so if you were to intentionally
misgender a trans woman
that could put her at risk of murder you
understand that because people think
because i don't dance i hate to ruin
your polite discourse
thank you thank you for putting that in
this place
fourth installment a real conversation
changed my mind for those who haven't
seen the series this is just a a series
here where we
set up shop reel pick a controversial
topic
and uh allow people to change my mind
sit down unedited you get to see what
happens when a real conversation
transpires not set up to be a debate
just a conversation
we sit up at a campus today is there are
only two genders change my mind you will
see
three different people a full hour of
change my mind today uh
in chronological order and i wanted you
to see specifically
three different approaches three
different tacts from the people
uh who were trying to change my mind
regardless of the fact that we didn't
change ours so
it's important to see that sometimes it
doesn't matter what you do it doesn't
matter how you treat people they are
coming in
i guess we can say cocked and loaded and
after the video you can stick around to
um
see where you can buy the change my mind
shirts and become a part of the champion
army let's go
it's all so magical
to meet you okay so um you know
this is just a series we do or let
people know my point of view there are
two genders go ahead and change my mind
it's the opposite of cable news we're
not going to edit anything out of
context
you said you disagreed i'm open to new
ideas
well i'm i'm wondering
i'm wondering the phrasing of the
question are you arguing that
um there's not more than like men and
women are you arguing there's not a
difference between sex and gender or
yeah i think i think they're two genders
male and female
okay so you're saying that male and
female is a gender not a sex
yes okay so okay
and see that's that's where i would have
to disagree okay
male and male and female is something
that uh would be by breath for example
uh you probably have a penis a male sex
organ
as would i but why would you assume that
yeah
do you but you assumed it though okay i
did i apologize
no you don't listen you don't need
anything i'm not trying to do any gotcha
yeah it's interesting to me that you
assumed that i have a penis
why
[Music]
because you uh seem
uh i don't know man because is it
because of societal construct
yes that's why yes it wasn't because of
my bone structure
or my penis bulge
that male and female is different than
being
a man or a woman okay and the fact that
we have
as a society created man man and the
male gender roles and just says women
gender roles
uh just as we would um anything else the
same way that we would say that
uh i don't know that music is good or
that we have created it to place people
into
roles and so i'm saying that if you were
male or female if you identified more as
a man and the gender roles that go with
being a man
that you have that so you're saying so
you're saying that that
sex and gender are very different yes
okay i understand that's your premise
um so that's based on on kind of modern
gender theory
uh when did that start i i wouldn't know
okay so why let me ask you this before i
guess before we get to the history
why do you accept that premise
uh because it makes uh
it makes the most sense to me i mean uh
the
argument that we've created roles such
as
um being being feminine and we have
associated it with being
female as opposed to being female is
being feminine
sure you unders you understand that
they're inconsistencies there for
example with your presumption of my you
know my penis
um let me ask you this then how many
genders are there
uh i would say if we're um we would say
that there are
two genders being men and uh man and
woman
and then that there would be people that
don't accept either of those
and that would be in a x or
non-identifying
category what's what's the number how
many genders are there i would i can
tell you
isn't that important um
i mean they were the point is that
before you know uh 1948 with simone de
beauvoir and then judith butler
with modern sort of post-modernism
feminism theory
gender and sex were effectively
interchangeable you can even look on
legal documentation depending on the
permit they are legally interchangeable
i mean this is the way it's been with
societies for millennia we've had male
and female
um so when you radically change that
you do have to have a number in in my
opinion and
some kind of an end game it can't just
be we're going to shift the rules based
on how people feel
so i can understand if someone says hey
you're wrong that there's difference
between sex and gender
but the burden of proof at that point
would be on the person asserting that
they're different
to tell me how many genders there are
because we the society right have to
know this
we have to function within certain
parameters um
and i would say that those those
parameters for
gender would be whatever that person
wants those parameters to be if they
identify as a man or a woman
or they don't identify that would be
their prerogative and that
it's not my place or your place to tell
them that
they have to identify with being a man
even if they are male
or they have to identify as a woman even
if they are female
but we but we do that all the time
people want to be things that they
aren't and we say that's not the case
you know this we constantly do that as a
society so i don't understand why it's
i'm really sorry to interrupt your
conversation but i have some logistical
questions for you
my name is laura chad and i work at smu
student activities yes we manage the
outdoor events request process um
are you the sponsor of this activity
it's college republicans actually and
you can speak with uh
darren wherever darren is he spoke with
drew we have a permission so
okay thank you very much so so i'd like
to continue on that thought uh
where were we sorry i forgot uh you were
talking about um
we have uh we do it all the time we do
it all the time so
why why is it a problem to do it if
someone we know biologically is a male
or a female um and that can never be
changed
it can never be changed biologically uh
but someone chooses to say that they're
not
that's a very that's a very modern idea
um
and the question is why do we now have
to subscribe to that and then it gets in
the idea of compulsion of language
compelling language
you know gender pronouns
what's allowed what's hate speech right
it's it's a fundamental
re-transformation of society based on
from what i'm hearing from you unless
i'm mistaken abstract
i haven't heard a number i haven't heard
what defines male or female
only how people feel and i just that's
to me that's not
very convincing or conducive toward a
productive society
okay and i would uh and i would argue
that
um reason we're talking about uh
like like you said when i assumed that
you had a penis when i have no idea if
you have a penis or not
um and saying that people i got a nice
big penis there okay
and so that people when people subscribe
to being
you you would say you see somebody that
uh you would presume to be male
and you asked and you would assume that
they would identify as being a man
sure um as you did yeah yes and uh
and so if um but if you had told me
that you are that you um in fact don't
identify as being a man that you
identify as being a woman
i would believe that would be wrong of
me to try and
uh subscribe you to being a man when you
say you identify as a woman
what if i told you that i believe i am a
bobcat
good for you man but would you accept
that would it be wrong if you did not
accept it
yes really okay well listen i appreciate
your intellectual consistency why would
it be wrong of you
to not accept my identification as a
bobcat
because uh if you id if you
identify as a bobcat man go for it great
for you
i hope you're the best bobcat on the
[ __ ] earth man
well i appreciate listen i think you're
a nice guy i hope it's been productive
and you you
i believe this has been civil but um you
do see obviously this is very this is a
very emotive
uh argument that you're making right
you're making an argument from a very
emotional
place and i think it's because you're
compassionate it's because you're a good
person but
and i appreciate your intellectual
consistency but the ramifications
of saying that we have to acknowledge
somebody legally who identifies as a
bobcat
you understand would be insurmountable
the ramifications would be all sorts of
new legal identifications that would be
required which don't currently exist
why the conversation i would love it if
you want to sit down afterwards
and i would love to sit down and have
continue this conversation i would
well are you thank you thomas are you
done yeah i appreciate it thomas
thank you madison i'm co-president of
spectrum the lgbt organization on campus
great love to talk to you about this
great thank you madison
my name's stephen okay uh i appreciate
it
uh you sitting down and um what is it
that you disagree with
so um i think you happen to be you're
confused on the idea of
gender versus sex i'm confused okay yeah
okay so
when we say there are only two genders
we often confuse the idea of gender and
sex
shorts is a generalization of xy
chromosomes so we assume that
our you know xy xx you know combination
of chromosomes
um so we assume that you know male and
female comes from your chromosomes right
but uh
that's really just the idea that there's
only two possibilities of sex
right so even within sex itself you know
you can
be born uh intersex which means that
you're born with
sexual characteristics of both what we
would consider male and female
and then you have gender and gender is
more about a mental state based off of
societal
norms so within our western society we
often discuss
gender as being binary meaning that
there's two options sure so boy
girl man woman however in other
societies non-western societies there
are more than
two options okay can i can i ask you a
couple questions there to unpack
um appreciate you taking the time by the
way so what was your your name madison
madison
madison so let's go to the sex concept
before gender i think because
the idea of gender being different from
sex is predicate on the other the idea
that sex is
um binary that's where you mention that
term gender binary so you mentioned
intersex
okay i'm aware of intersex now of course
intersex doesn't necessarily mean that
someone is completely between sexes
usually they have very identifiable
characteristics like a very large
clitoris
or micro penis in that case it also
affects point zero eight
people think this is funny it's just
true less than point zero eight percent
of the population earth they still but
they still exist let me ask you this in
human anatomy class
uh how many fingers are you taught human
beings have uh we're told typically that
people have 10 however there are people
born with 11. but you're taught 10 right
yeah so we don't teach people there are
people born with 11 fingers are people
born with 12 fingers yeah but we don't
completely dismiss that those people
exist just because that they're uncommon
do we
we teach that human beings have 10
fingers
i would wager that everyone here has
been taught yeah human beings have ten
figures of course there are anomalies
that's the same way that we treat
intersex or these as you said you
mentioned chromosomes genetic
abnormalities that are very
a very extreme case so i think what we
need to do is remove this extreme case
with sex just as we would with how many
fingers toes how many kidneys you have
how many
feet you have there's something that's
typical or something that's atypical
then you go to gender this is where
listen i'm open everyone has said sex is
different
from gender and gender is not non-binary
um so i would like allow you to kind of
unpack that for me
yeah so uh in western society at least
so in our country in our society we bel
we tend to think of gender to be on this
binary spectrum of
you don't well not even really a
spectrum just a binary so you have man
woman and that's it those are the only
two options
however gender really is more of a
spectrum so
it's non-binary there are not just two
options okay you have
man woman and then everything that
doesn't fit into just man and woman is
considered non-binary that's an umbrella
term
and that includes a lot of different
categorizations so how many genders are
there
i can't you can't put a number on the
number of genders because everyone uses
different words to classify themselves
i would disagree i'm not that's worth
change my i'm not convinced that anyone
can just use any classification for
themselves for their gender
and certainly not that then we have to
compel society
to address them this way right i'm sure
you can understand that the compelling
of language is an issue so what gender
do you think you are
well i'm a male okay well i think maybe
i think you're a woman
no legally i'm a male oh it says on my
driver's license that i'm a male
okay so that's your sex no it's a yeah
but i'm also a man
that's your sense it says on my carry
certificate that i'm a male gender some
legal documentation
say gender what if i say i don't believe
you it doesn't matter exactly it doesn't
matter if you don't believe me no it
doesn't matter because biologically what
gender do you think i am
i would assume you're a female yeah so
you're making assumptions
yes i identify as non-binary yeah i
don't respectfully it doesn't matter
it does matter now let me ask you this
what would you say if i have
what pronouns you use for me it matters
how i'm socialized in society it matters
my gender expression
it matters the way that i'm allowed to
express myself it matters what bathroom
i use it matters who i'm allowed to live
with it affects every aspect of my life
so you're saying
what pronoun should i use you should use
they them pronouns so you're saying that
what if i don't what if i don't if you
don't i would consider that
disrespectful and that's actually an act
of violence to misgender a trans
it's an act of violence that is an act
of violence to intentionally misgender
someone
here we come to the issue and this is
why i'm out here um you just said that's
an act of violence that means it's an
actionable offense that means it's a
crime
so you believe that for me it's a crime
i said it's an act of violence
that are not considered crimes are acts
of violence okay so you believe it's a
non-aggressive act of violence i think
that
okay when you misgender someone if you
were to misgender a trans woman
yes trans women especially trans women
of color
are the most or have the highest rate of
murder within the lgbt community right
so if you were to intentionally
misgender a trans woman
that could put her at risk of murder you
understand that because people think
because
i don't understand i'm sorry it does
show that you're privileged in the
situation then
yes i believe we're both i think you're
extremely privileged in the situation
that you don't have to experience that
or that you don't have to worry about
that or consider that that you don't
feel like you need to respect people's
pronouns i'm i'm considering this i'm
asking you questions
you said these are the pronouns i need
to use i said what if i don't you so
that's an act of violence yeah i would
say i'm trying
to act to violence against me okay so
that's a crime an act of violence
against you as a crime i would consider
that
i would consider you being disrespecting
me as a person and that's not okay and
that's not even ethical that it doesn't
matter if it's legal it's not ethical
and i don't know how you can do
something that's considered unethical i
don't know how you cannot allow me to
speak and ask
questions based on your own premises
please this is we're trying to keep this
civil i haven't yelled at you
i haven't accused you of anything you're
getting very heated you said that's an
act of violence
that's a crime okay i didn't say that
was a crime an act of violence
an act of violence against you was a
crime so i did not say that
you said it is an act of violence
against i said it's an act of violence
and i said misgendering anyone's an act
yes you said it is an act of violence
against that person that is in fact a
crime
so here's my question since we've now
decided we don't know the number of
genders
it's a spectrum it exists there is no
set number you've asserted the premise
that
we are required to use the pronouns that
are preferred by the individual we have
no idea how many pronouns there are we
can never know how many pronouns there
are and to not use a proper pronoun
you could ask is an act of violence
against them did you ask my pronouns
before you sat down
no i didn't ask your pronouns because i
haven't referred to you with pronouns
you didn't ask my pronoun so you just
said you can ask yeah you can ask what
are your pronouns
but you didn't ask what are your
pronouns you just talked about me being
privileged you understand no one goes
around asking pronouns before they speak
with people
i ask and sort of ask of a restructuring
of society
i did ask you how based on a number
that's not tangible
with gender versus sex is something that
is uh incredibly corrosive so i'll ask
you how you identify yourself
no i don't believe so yes i did i did
actually you said you identify as male
and that would
after the conversation okay well let's
let's say that sure so we need to ask
pronouns
before every person and if we don't use
those pronouns yeah
how many pronouns are there they're it's
the same kind of thing there aren't like
would you
just so people can see the sign would it
be okay if you just step aside for just
a second no there's nothing
thank you very much there's no limited
number of pronouns no i would say the
typical ones are she her hers
him his her his sorry him
he him his and they them theirs those
are the typical number of pronouns we
usually use three
okay so i just want to again the goal is
here to change my i'm open to new ideas
there's no set kind of space around them
yeah the different kind of space around
us i think i don't know no one's being
accosted here we're just having a
conversation there's no question of a
costume we're just trying to like
bring the conversation so that it's not
like a kind of like
stage spectacle kind of deal so like
we're all in conversation around and we
can
like engage with your signature sure i
appreciate it but it's but it's not
though actually it's a conversation
between
two willing participants right now and i
will go other people talking as well
though i'm not
i don't consent so um this is your setup
and we're supposed to just follow your
rules
yes when one is invited and we've gotten
the proper permissions and i've said
open campus a college campus sure it's
an open campus
you can do whatever you want you can
protest but it doesn't mean that we're
i'm going to be engaging in conversation
with the crowd
no that's not incorrect but i would but
i would love to continue my conversation
here
so when we talk about gender and sex
right this is a very new idea you said
in western society it's not a new idea
really no it's not so when did when did
gender theory start when did gender and
sex become separate
well they're actually it's not
necessarily the idea of gender theory
it's the idea that there have been
different genders
outside of man woman for centuries okay
how so yeah
uh indian culture yeah you know they
have their gender native american
cultures they have
their genders in ancient egypt they had
their genders okay
you know so that's a very it's a very
western idea to say that there are only
two genders and that this whole thing is
a new idea changing
you know what else has a very western id
so it seems to me your your
presupposition there
correct me if i'm wrong is that because
other cultures have done this there's a
precedent
yeah i don't think that we're
hermetically sealed in any way so you do
realize um and you
talk about how very different it was
from western culture so antithetical to
western culture you named india ancient
egypt
you know what else uh we also believe in
that synthetic of those cultures
we're against slavery
i'm sorry i'm so i'm really confused why
you brought slavery let me let me learn
about gender i would love to bring it up
yeah it's kind of that's kind of
my point is because your premise is
because it's found in other societies
therefore it's okay or it is to be good
my point is there are plenty of other
practices well i'm trying to get to why
i believe it's harmful and you're
explaining why you don't but the point
is if something was practiced in another
society
and it was harmful in another society
and we agree that it's harmful for
example we both agree that slavery was
harmful we both agree that maybe
cannibalism is harmful you can find
these practices in societies
my point is it's not a valid argument to
simply say it's been found in other
societies
if that practice is harmful so it comes
down to the idea of
is it productive or harmful for us to
separate the idea of sex and gender on a
form
like you said the ramifications for that
in legalism so that's that's the
question
so other societies have done harmful
things i think you can agree that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's i'm
sorry
it's okay i don't think respecting
someone's identity makes that harmful
i don't understand i think i don't agree
with you comparing
gender identity to cannibalism or
slavery that seems
pretty offensive i know it seems you
think a lot of what i've said is
offensive you've been set up here from
the get-go for it to be offensive and
i'm not trying to offend
let me re-explain what it is take any
practice okay
take the practice of neck stretching for
example which is not harmful
okay it is harmful actually okay well
some people don't think it's harmful
they don't think it's harmful in these
societies take any practice that's
relatively benign that we believe to be
harmful that they don't believe to be
harmful
the point is just because another
society at one point has practiced it
doesn't make it correct can we agree on
that
i i'm sorry i just i think you're making
really false comparisons
no i'm not i do i think can we agree can
we agree
because listen there are also many
societies the other way right who've
only ever recognized two genders
two sexes but that doesn't matter that's
most other genders don't exist that's
most so
you're implying that those societies
were wrong i'm i'm implying that they
have their other societal standards
right societal standards are based off
of a lot of things it's very
intersectional
what we decide to accept in society so
if you're going to say
well because you it's society can be
really making the same art yeah society
can be wrong society was wrong about gay
marriage
you know i think people are wrong saying
that you know
gay marriage being gay is unnatural and
being gay is a crime not society being
wrong but you know what
we adapt to modern times and i think
that we need well you just compared us
to ancient egypt and india as though
that was a valid argument for convincing
me
why they actually this isn't an ancient
practice this is still going on sure in
other countries this is still good
you just said it's not fair to use other
societal comparisons
no no no no no i'm trying to get to the
premise of the argument
i'm trying to get to the premise trying
to get to the premise of your argument
here okay
i'm trying to keep this as very
respectful as possible you said this has
been practiced in other societies for a
long time
yeah my point is that's not an argument
because there have been horrible things
maybe benign things maybe semi-harmful
things in other societies
we would both agree on that so it's not
a valid way to bring slavery back then
no one is
going to bring slavery exactly so why
are you actually of course it still
exists in other countries in the middle
east and some countries that you've
mentioned like i said i just i don't
think you're making a fair comparison i
think
i think i'm making a very fair i think
you're kind of just going on a tangent
in order to try
my point is it's not it's not an
argument it is an argument i think it's
an argument okay so i will already i
will use your
western standards are not necessarily
the pinnacle of what we should be doing
western societal standards do not mean
that we all need to be following the
same thing
because we're not all western and we
don't all follow those beliefs
so if a native american
yeah okay so yeah the law is different i
think the law is different than a
societal a societal standard
so legally how is the law different it
is the societal
standard legally legally yeah yeah
yeah but stay within those parameters
okay sure
so um and other there's other countries
that are
considered western that would recognize
that their gender sure
yeah yeah i know that mm-hmm okay so why
not so how many genders are there it
comes back to if we're going to
if we're going to change this statement
so we are um sitting here talking about
gender yeah so if i were
so as a this is a modern theory in the
united
no i'm going to st one sentence here
okay i would appreciate that you've been
very privileged in speaking over me
um i'm not convinced right the job here
is for you to sit down and change my
mind i think it's very productive for
you to do with other people on campus
right i don't think this is a way to
change somebody's mind i don't think you
want your mind changed
i i i've had my mind changed well
instead of instead of assuming that
how about actively trying to change it
so my point is
you've mentioned that it's non-binary
but you haven't given me a number of
genders
and how we restructure society you've
merely pointed out that it's an act of
violence to use an improper pronoun and
see i think that would have
you just talked about a societal
standard if the societal standard is
using the wrong pronoun is an act of
violence against somebody
i think that's an incredibly dangerous
societal standard and it's one that
nobody can uphold consistently
would we not agree i said i mean
intentionally using the wrong gender i
mean when you know someone's pronouns
you intentionally use the wrong pronouns
because you don't agree with them or you
don't recognize their identity to be
real
that's an act of violence because that's
purposely disrespecting someone
you no one wants to be purposefully
disrespected i i
believe me i understand you the wrong
name all the time how would you feel
i i would feel very disrespected if you
for example came in bombastically and
other people interrupting i'd feel very
disrespected
she developed that active violence thing
like where does that take us if someone
uses the offensive pronoun
yeah so it's intentionally using the
wrong pronoun so if you ask someone
their pronouns or they would correct you
and say
no sorry these are my correct pronouns
and you continue to
disrespect them you have to understand
how much
that puts a trans person at risk yeah
does that person go to get arrested for
using the wrong pronoun or
like it's an act of violence active
violence i don't and i know that you
like to say that an act of violence mean
that it's legally
a crime it is that's not how i'm
defining an act of violence it doesn't
matter how you define an act of violence
this is
the thing we have to have how you define
an act of violence no matter how the law
defines the act of violence
i don't think it does you don't think it
matters how the law defines that no i do
i'm saying that an act of violence does
not have to mean that it's a
crime i'm saying that it's an act of
violence against another person an
unwilling participant
is in fact a crime legally there's no
way around that can we agree on that
how about can we agree on that let's
find some common ground can we agree an
act of violence against somebody else is
a crime
and no one should commit it i'm saying
no one should commit i'm not going to
say that it's necessarily illegal
like okay but it is illegal criminal
defense i'll allow i'll allow you to
assume what you want but it is illegal
i would like you to finish your earlier
thought but i think this is a very
central point to the argument
because this is one of the first things
that you've said yeah and we haven't
found common ground we don't agree on
that
i do find that the idea of yeah no i'm
sorry can i hear what she has to say
questions and she wants to take my
question so since this is an equal setup
yeah so no i appreciate that afterwards
and we'll have a conversation you know
listen i would like to have a
conversation with one person and then
you can all line up and have one-on-one
conversation
but i do i don't consent so
i'll have a one-on-one conversation i
have the microphone so that it's not
just you shoving the microphone in here
i'm not shoving a microphone in her face
i'm simply holding it that's what you're
doing
so let her have the microphone but you
just said this isn't this is not an
equal setup i've paid for this
microphone
this is my microphone so would you like
to would you like to
have her take your place i'd like to
finish my thought that you haven't let
me finished yet actually okay
do we have a time code do we have a time
code i believe it's been about
over 30 minutes but go ahead yeah so i
would like to finish my thought because
i it actually hasn't been over 30
minutes it's been less than 30 minutes
okay go ahead um so my thought is that
you talk about legal ramifications how
many genders are there
okay so when you have countries that
recognize their genders
or non-binary gender options you know
how they put that on their form
non-binary other yeah third gender
right how is that complicated well can
can i tell you how it's problematic how
is that problematic it's problematic
because you have people who've been sued
arrested or put out of business for
unknowingly using the improper pronouns
and that's the point that i'm making
there's been you're referring to a
societal standard what can be filled out
on a form
that's your premise i'm saying there's
been a societal standard one that's
biologically based
for millennia which we've now changed
and we're punishing people who don't
agree so you may think it's
disrespectful for someone to not use the
pronouns that you demand
i think it's equally respect
disrespectful to demand that somebody
live in a spectrum that hasn't been
agreed to and they don't even understand
how what businesses have been put out
what who's been put out of business
we're not using the right pronouns
in the uk this happens all the time in
canada you know bill clinton specific
business
yeah both c16 and canada is really
important for example we have
we have comedians who've been put for
human rights tribunals
of their gender though it can't yeah
canada doesn't legally recognize
their gender so the law is their legal
standard that's their societal standard
right so the people who aren't you
agreeing with that aren't agreeing with
their societal standards right but it's
a
standard that flies in the face of
biology and my issue is a standard
that's legal
so do you believe that people should be
put before human rights tribunals for
using the improper
gen gender is biology it was until 1948.
you know that right
uh no i don't agree with you on that i'm
sorry okay but when did gender theory
start
i don't know the your gender theory
started i'm sorry i'm not a human
encyclopedia
okay it was 1948 simone de bever and
judith butler these are people by the
way when he started it there were still
only two genders
gender was a grammatical issue usually
used to refer to as a noun
i'm french canadian so in french we have
masculine and feminine right
it really is a very new concept and one
that is not rooted in any kind of
biological precedent
to say that there are unlimited genders
that's the issue and so when you are
jailing people and punishing people
for not adhering to an entirely new
system that you yourself hasn't
that you haven't defined i do think that
that's a problem i think saying that
somebody using
improper pronouns is an act of violence
against someone i just disagree i think
that's
i think it's a real problem and i would
hate to say it's disrespectful i think
it's disrespectful to force somebody to
use pronouns
i think they're being invented by the
day if i told they're not being invented
by the day i don't know where you're
getting that information
how many genders are there how many
pronouns are there they're i can't
define the number of genders or the
number of pronouns exactly because
anyone can determine them
they are being invented by the day new
genders each day so
if i told you that i identified as you
know
if i said hey i want you to use just my
name not my pronouns sure does that make
you uncomfortable
no right that wasn't hard was it
no it wasn't hard yeah exactly that's
what people are asking you to do
no yeah you know as a matter of fact you
have people you have a ta we just had
her on the program yesterday
who uh sorry on monday who got in
trouble for
using the student's name because a
student demanded that he use fem
use masculine pronouns even though she
was a girl and he said listen i'm not
comfortable with that i will use her
name masculine pronouns i believe that
person would
be using masculine pronouns and you just
misgendered them
yeah you used the name you said he used
the name yes
yeah i did because she's a female um
that's not how that works i think
that is how that works so we established
that is how that works you agreed with
me previously that we
and we established previously gender and
sex are totally different no i don't
agree
how do you know that person's a female i
i know that because of biology and
you're thinking gender theory look at
them did you did you like happen to just
like examine them and decide that
person's a female because of what you
saw
is there external genitalia can i ask
you a question yeah do you genuinely
feel that i've been interrupting you
more than me you keep saying you're not
able to finish a thought i haven't
finished a phrase
i think you just finished the phrase
okay do we do we want to score points or
do we want to be i think you've been
interrupting me quite a bit
and you just assumed a premise that i
don't agree with no i that's my point
that i've not been able to make is
gender theory as you're describing it is
very new
it started with simone de bever in 1948
and what you're discussing is the idea
that actually came with judith butler
the only the first time there was this
idea that there were more than two
genders was john money
i'm sure you're familiar with that case
um that's very new
i don't and there's no biological
backing behind this theory it is based
on an emotive response so i don't agree
that gender and
sex are separate legal documentation
sometimes don't say they're separate
we're trying to adapt that now
based on how people feel and i don't
think that we should adapt the law
considering something an act of violence
because someone uses
a pronoun which is biologically correct
because
you consider an act of violence against
you what's a biological pronoun
he her his how do we determine that
whether they're male or female yeah but
how do we determine that
what if we decided that she her hers was
what we were going to use for males it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter we right now yeah
right we have male and female
his or her standard right no it's a
biological standard
the words that we use are based off of
like what we as a society use though
not entirely yeah they're reflections
this is pretty societally based okay i
would say
amphibian what about amphibians is that
societally based
an amphibian is a is it i don't
you know i'm not a science major but i
will say an amphibian is a like
scientific classification of an isle
mm-hmm yeah it's a classification of an
animal species
bush tree blueberry yeah okay are these
societal terms
the point is that language is a
reflection of standards that we have a
society are doctors
sexist i think some doctors are sex are
doctors transphobic if they refer to
their patients who have a penis and they
come in for a prostate exam as a male
is that dr hate speaking is that an act
of aggression i think if that doctor
misgenders their patient then yeah they
are being transphobic
okay well i don't i my mind has not
changed but i think uh
and i tried to find some common ground
i'm sorry that we didn't i'm sorry
i'm sorry that you feel that way yeah
thank you madison i'm not gonna shake
her
i figured
[Music]
nice to meet you thank you hey i'm doing
well thurman how are you
steven nice to meet you thurman sorry
yeah by the way if you would like to
hold the microphone you can she never
asked
i told you my okay and you continue to
disrespect me thank you
appreciate that okay here's the thing
that was actually by accident
because i've been using he and her for
my entire life it's not men is an act of
disrespect and
now you see the problem in claiming
that's an act of violence against
somebody
sometimes i'm sure you can establish
intent with every person you encounter
thurman how are you sir
fantastic yeah it seems like there have
been people who've gotten into a fight
at the dinner table
and then we all have to put a good face
on but thurman i'm i'm glad to have you
here i'm open to having my mind changed
um so i'll just break this down for you
basically
yeah so i think
i'm sure i move here and your last
exchange basically
you guys are trying to establish like
sex and gender which technically are
different
um and sex usually is
boiled down to more of you know
reproductive
uh potentials and gender as like a
lifestyle
and everything like that more societal
yeah okay
yeah yeah okay i really don't know what
to make of the uh
of the new like gender standards now as
in terms of like
you know people just living whatever
lifestyle they want so if
let's say someone that appears to be you
know female
lives a male's lifestyle i don't
understand
where we transition to like having new
classifications and everything like that
but technically speaking there are
sexualities spectrum and gender is a
spectrum right so
you have you know your typical healthy
male your ex-wife you have your typical
healthy female xx
so if you have something like klein
filters right
now this isn't just i think there's
variations of how many x-rays can i say
one one question there yeah why do you
say healthy xxxy
um healthy meaning basically the
standard
non-deviant what people will consider
normal okay
yeah so if you have climb filters right
technically speaking
um that would be
non-binary and that's not a lifestyle
thing that actually is a biological
thing sure so
we discuss people who are intersex yeah
yeah yeah so you'll have like and that's
not to say they're hermaphrodites
because
we don't have that in our species but
you know allowed the two exes and the
wide of under uh
underdeveloped male uh
sex um machinery um
it's okay it's not going it's not
they call it micro penis it's been used
as an insult but it's an actual term
yeah what you're referring to
or enlarged clitoris these are these are
medical conditions as you're discussing
they have enlarged breasts you know
smaller you know male reproductive
organs high pitched voices you know gino
mastica
yeah yeah so sure in that case and i'm
not disagreeing with that yeah so in
that case
yes there's no debate you know you
technically are both
sex wise and gender i i honestly have no
idea
how to choose that that really kind of
depends on sure
like how like severe how severe cases
sure um can i can i address a couple
things here maybe fill up with some
questions
um we talked about it earlier with
intersex you know it affects such a
small percent of the population
yeah um and most these people actually
have very identifiable um
you know sexes but generally speaking
it's not just right in the middle it'd
be considerably talked about like the
previous conditions you mentioned men
with these conditions or female with
these conditions that's often the
the rule with intersex not always right
but um as we said we teach there are
people have two feet now some people
don't have two feet
in anatomy class we teach people have
ten toes we teach people have
one heart we teach people have one head
all of these things have exceptions to
the rules right all these medical
aspects
so the point is we don't use extreme
exceptions
to define our rules as a matter of fact
that's how we consider those exceptions
yeah um so biologically sex
male and female this is how it's been
taught i think we would all agree that
but sex has been taught that way
and then you've talked about gender you
said you're not entirely sure so i would
like to hear your thoughts
your opinions on on gender how that
differs
from sex and how we define it uh
just by definition gender is basically
like your lifestyle like choices your
lifestyle rose so
if you were saying like brother would
you like some water i know it's hot out
here
no okay i appreciate it no so like if
you're finding rose right so like uh
like let's say like corden so you know
steve you ask a girl
you know you think she's cute you say
courting yeah yeah
i ask a dame i ask i ask i go court a
dame i love it you're using an old
terminal
no no i like it it's very respectful
recording that means you're a gentleman
yeah so uh anyway so yeah you know you
see a girl you know she's cute
you take her out you asked her you pay
you know typically this how that goes so
that would be like
your gender roles at your gender role as
a man
okay yeah well you mentioned gender
roles
right and i hear that a lot we say
gender roles so are we to
mean that gender as you know
authenticated through whatever
documentation we provide right now or
how we have to identify people
are we really just saying is gender a
synonym for gender roles
gender roles is the behavior of your
gender does that make sense so like how
you like identify
somebody's gender sure is basically like
their lifestyle
choice just by definitions well i'm only
i'm only asking this again none of this
is gotcha i'm asking because when i
asked you
how gender was different you said it was
more it was performative it was based on
behavior
yeah you said but now you've said gender
roles are behavioral so what's the
difference between
gender and gender roles so it's a
synonym yeah yeah
okay certain genders have certain roles
okay
yeah okay sx is a more physical thing so
my question is i'm interested why did
you
say gender was different from sex but
then you said someone might
you use the term gender role differently
but now
you are saying that it's effectively the
same yeah well i used uh gender role
basically in relation to
like your behavior basically you and the
girl you
have separate rules and you believe that
determines gender
um that's a slippery slope when you use
that language um
that's why i'm just confused and i want
to i think we need to set something
concrete especially if it's an act of
violence against somebody
that's
[Laughter]
no i'm just i just want i think it's
important would you agree i mean i think
more what they were getting at
was uh they were trying to say like it's
assault
which is more like verbal and battery
better more like physical thing
uh either way both are a crime so it
doesn't change the premise yeah
you can both get tickets i don't have
the right to assault you
yeah nor bad are you nor you me i hope
you don't yeah i think we're getting a
little out of hand though uh with uh
you know if you're filling out a form
and putting like the non-binary
option there's really no way of knowing
you know sure
and uh i gotta be honest it's really
going out of your way if i like
say hey steve uh you know
you didn't ask me my pronouns i didn't
ask you your pronouns yeah i mean you
know i'm not like coming at you like
deliberately trying to
you know disrespect you like if i knew
right you know
you referred something different i would
be like hey i wouldn't be like hey bro
you know but i have no way of knowing
that right like a guy to me
so well i mean we've had many
transgender people on our show when i
use the pronouns they prefer
uh but sometimes you make a mistake
listen when someone identifies as
you have people sometimes who just look
like men and they say i'm a woman
there's no standard anymore as to how
you identify you know we used to we used
to determine this is why i say it's new
water there used to be transvestites you
know uh you know we talked about
security director hoover
right uh men who dress anymore what is
that no that's that's a
this is important because i'm confused
with this as well and i spoke with a
psychiatrist
and she said that legally it's very
difficult for her to go by the dsm-5
determines gender dysphoria so we used
to have transvestites those were for
example men who dressed cross-dressers
and then we had transsexuals and these
were people who went through sex change
operations and therapy
right so these were the terms so the
pretty modern term
is transgender said we have to use the
right term now transgender can be
somebody who goes through hormone
replacement therapy
transgender can be somebody who goes
through as a matter of fact the vast
majority of them don't get
bottom don't get the sex change at all
transgender could be just as simple as
someone who dresses up like a woman and
identifies as a woman
so that's new we used to have
transvestite transsexual gender
we said is however somebody identifies
and there are legal ramifications i'm
trying to see if there's an objective
standard
and if that objective standard is
conducive towards i think transgender is
more of a behavioral thing just like i
was saying like your gender roles or how
you act and uh you know
positions relative to other people uh
and they're defined differently in
different cultures you know
uh just like maybe over east the woman
might i ask you
and that would be the female role right
in that society
but uh yeah no i would think transsexual
would be like the actual like you know
hormone therapy and everything like that
that's very offensive now
what yeah transsexual can be very
offensive now just like you said healthy
chromosomes can also be considered
offensive
yeah there is there are legal
ramifications depending on the country
and that's my point if it's a
never-ending shifting landscape of
what's okay and what's not okay
i don't think that's fair right um let
me ask you this what about uh
so you said that transgender i think you
have a bit of a different opinion than
some people here i find that interesting
you said transgender is behavioral
so you don't believe that transgender is
a biological issue
well just by definition it's not it's
not really something i believe
i'm not trying to be like a dick or
anything but like no no no no that's
okay
like sex is the physical you know your
representation and then gender is
completely different
um like i said with the klein felters
technically speaking like you do have
like
characteristics of both sexes but sure
in terms of um
in terms of like you being you know
biologically set
so if you're xy and you feel like a
woman um
i i'm not saying that we should
necessarily try to oppress that
because people do you know have
different identities especially with the
youth
i'm like 22 you know young people uh you
are really kind of trying to
you know trying to find your way in this
world sure uh but at the same time i
don't think we should uh
overlook it uh like it's non-deviant
behavior and i don't mean deviant like
evil or anything like that because
technically you're using the series
the proper termination deviant means to
deviate from the norm i mean it's in
mathematical terms people get triggered
and you know
yes so yeah so i don't mean that and
like you know like i hope you have your
own security here when you
i'm used to this but um i'm actually
from chicago i'm like left-centered but
you know
chicago you have to keep one do you
still sleep with one eye open uh
well i appreciate you taking the time i
i do know we other people want to line
up and the reason i ask you that is
because a lot of people say well listen
transgenderism
and this is what's important because
we're we're actively trying to remove
the term
gender dysphoria the dsm-5 is what
determines gender dysphoria
it's actually a clinical condition
meaning someone's body dysmorphias
bodybuilders are often considered to
have body dysmorphia right they view
some but we
view that as unhealthy you know
bodybuilder can look in the mirror for
example after steroids and come down off
a cycle and say
you know oh man i'm a wimp and they're
huge that's body dysmorphia we often
give them counseling
well if you look at the suicide rate you
look at the medical issues
whether it's pre or post-op it's very
very high in the transgender
community and they are treating it right
now as a biological one right
you've said it biological what
transgenderism you said it was
behavioral
but if we now are no longer saying hey
gender dysphoria
is is uh non-productive it's actually
corrosive
to simply put someone on hormone simply
provide a sex change operation we can't
do that so we're performing these
operations now
which ends up actually altering people's
not your dna
but your hormonal profile your equipment
so we're treating it as a biological
issue yeah i think there's a lot of
variables especially considering the age
i think
especially if you're a teenager still
you should kind of hold off
no matter what you feel you know
teenagers think they know everything
you know what i mean it's kind of like
that weird i do many college students
yeah but uh you know you're 13 you think
you're grown you're 16
still think you're growing 19 you feel
like a child again you start questioning
things
uh i mean people who are older you know
in their 30s and 40s i think we can uh
leave them to their own devices as to
what they um
what they're thinking and what they're
identifying with but when you get into
you know kind of shady situations like a
16 year old saying they want to be this
or that sure and you you know go through
with it
i think it's risky i think you should
really
it's actually illegal in some places to
not do that there are actual there's
actually a doctor
in the uk who performed sex change
operations his whole life including with
children
uh young teenagers and uh he's since
said you know what the outcome has been
so negative i won't do it anymore
yeah and he's losing his practice yeah
so this is you can have really uh you
can have really significant effects uh
there was a kid
i think i think he was born a boy
and he said basically he liked you know
more things like he was a girl and right
away that was
misgendering you said born a boy
you see physically physically but do you
see how complicated it's difficult
but he was a small child but he was a
small child right and his parents
trusted him and you know they went
through the whole process
and then i don't want to say he changed
his mind uh
because that sounds a little crass but
basically
he just didn't want any part of that
anymore but they had already
physically altered them so yeah you know
that
i i would imagine as a matter of fact if
you do it young a lot of people don't
realize this and this is something that
the transgender community i'll be open
to anyone who wants to
maybe there's somebody disagree but the
platform right now certainly the
transgender community and politicians is
uh that puberty blocker should be
allowed
that these children you know that these
people should be allowed to just to stop
puberty as a matter of fact
and you just saw this problem actually
parents jazz jennings is a good example
you know jazz jennings i am jazz it's a
it's a reality show i didn't either
honestly to be fair that was the only
trick question here i found out about it
like four months ago
um jazz jennings is one of those famous
young transgenders has a reality series
well jazz jennings can't create a fake
vagina
because he never went through puberty
and developed a big enough penis
so because there's not enough tissue you
cannot invert it to create a vagina
but this is actually occurring i don't
know how old jaz jennings is now but
went through transition well before
teenage years
so but this is policy this is actually
what what the community
pushes for now there are exceptions to
the rule and i think that we have a lot
of reasonable transgenders to come on
the show and say hey
i support the idea of people being able
to do whatever they want to do go
through sex change operations by the way
i do too my issue is when you apply
societal standards to other people that
affect everyone else's lives that are
biologically inaccurate
and we say that misgendering someone is
offensive
well it's equally as aggressive to tell
someone that they have to use a pronoun
or a gender
that they've never heard of that doesn't
exist legally that's never been used yet
or they could potentially be guilty of a
crime that's my premise i'd agree
do you think they should change it so
that you are like legally required or
no i don't because they couldn't they
wouldn't be able to as you've heard from
the argument here they say i don't know
gender is a spectrum
you couldn't legally change it to a way
that would be standardized
that would protect freedom of speech
from people it's happened people slip up
all the time and they get
slapped with it so i thought well i
appreciate we do have i think there's
some other people lining up i don't want
to give you the boot but
i think it was really productive man i
appreciate it thank you i appreciate
thanks man
look at this your wallet is still there
it's not chicago anymore
yeah i was from detroit it's we're the
ones you guys point to say at least
we're not detroit so
i get it what uh what's i hate to ruin
your like polite discourse but
[ __ ] you thank you thank you for putting
that on this play for the whole world
you're [ __ ]
scum okay thank you
well she was actually as a matter of
fact just to clarify were we talking an
act of aggression
her touching me when i didn't want her
to touch me that's not assault that's
actually
battery so it's actually worse than
using the improper pronoun but i'm cool
with it
i'm not triggered hey youtube if you
like this video subscribe or of course
join my club at lottothecreditor.com
it's what allows us to do this kind of
anti-cable news content because you
support the content
off-site and we can do more content
on-site also at loudourcridershop.com is
where you can now buy the change my mind
t-shirts
so we have what pro-gone program and
pro-life pro-gun and pro-life will be
adding to it
and become a part of the change my mind
real conversation army now listen
there is some responsibility if you buy
one of these shirts yeah people will
approach you yeah
people will be ready to try and argue
with you your goal
your purpose should be in wearing this
shirt to actually have a conversation
and just just require that people
rationalize their own arguments you'd be
surprised as to how many minds you can
change don't be caustic
if you buy a shirt livecluttershop.com
let people
change your mind but maybe they'll learn
something about themselves